Razor crest stand down
i'm here on business i need your help i've
been quested to bring this one back to its kind
if i can locate other
mandalorians they can guide me
this is no place for a child
wherever i go he goes
here we go
the mandalorian new season streaming
october 30th only on disney flaws
show me the one whose safety
deemed such destruction
you must reunite it with its own kind
where this you must determine
the songs of eon's past tell of battles between
mandalore the great and an order of sorcerers
called jedi you expect me to search the galaxy and
deliver this creature to a race of enemy sorcerers
this is the way
Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is the way this is going to be my new mandalorian season 2 trailer video we got
a bunch of new footage a bunch of easter eggs
so we'll break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i will be doing videos for all the episodes during
season 2 just like season one you just gotta hold
out for a couple more weeks then things will be
alright so i'll just go through this shot by shot
and talk about easter eggs as we go along starting
with the voiceover of the rebel pilot yelling for
the mandalorian to stand down when they're chasing
in through the clouds it sounds kind of familiar
i can't quite place the voice but usually they
get special guest stars to do all those roles
so if someone sounds kind of familiar they're
probably someone special but usually you have to
wait till the actual episode drops to get them
in the credits to find out who it actually is
you also probably remember the special cameos
from season one there were three rebel pilots that
they had during episode six that was i believe
including dave filoni himself they actually used
the same x-wing to film all those scenes they
had a big behind the scenes for they just sort
of swapped out when they filmed each different
pilot filming their lines it's hard to tell which
planet they're on when this is happening but this
actually looks very reminiscent of cloud city when
lando ships chase the millennium falcon through
the clouds then it looks like he's crashing
on the ice planet it's hard to tell if this is
connected to the same scene of him being chased
by the x-wings or if it's just clever editing you
can never really tell sometimes but there are a
lot of theories about what this ice planet is is
it going to be hoth is it going to be another ice
planet is it going to be ilum the reason why illum
is such a sacred place to the jedi and important
for their history is because they went there for
thousands of years on pilgrimages to find kyber
crystals to use to construct their lightsabers the
problem in present day around the time that the
mandalorian is taking place is that by the time
we get to return of the jedi the emperor had strip
mined ilum of pretty much all the kyber crystals
so even though there are sacred jedi temples
that are there you couldn't actually go there to
find more kyber crystals to build new lightsabers
then within about 30 years of that by the time you
get to the events of the new trilogy and the force
awakens the first order wound up terraforming ilum
into the starkiller base so that obviously winds
up blowing up by the end of that movie because
they were going for a third death star reference
but after the movie came out they actually
revealed that that planet once was illum
regardless of which planet this actually winds
up being i have a feeling they're gonna go for
all the empire strikes back hoth references though
it's the second season the second story the second
movie started on a nice planet there's a bunch
of scenes of him fixing his ship just like he
did during season one episode two after the jawas
ripped it to shreds they had to spend several days
repairing it then he comes back to navarro with
baby yoda and he has that voice over asking for
help clasping hands with greek karga and cara dune
i think the voiceover though is from a totally
different scene because way back during season 1
episode 8 they were standing right there when the
armorer gave him his mission to take baby oda to
find his kind quote unquote the enemy sorcerers
tracking down more jedi that was the voice over
dialogue that they put in that last big trailer
so he wouldn't need to re-explain that mission
to them so whoever he's telling this story to
he's probably just talking to another new
character then we go back to tatooine in
a different scene as you go over the sand dunes
you actually see a bantha skeleton which is just
another reference to a new hope when you pass
over the crate dragon skeleton in the landscape
this is all probably from the same episode like
we have the other trailer footage of the tuscan
raider sitting on the bantha watching the razor
crest fly by in the sky but in this scene he's
on the same type of speeder bike that they were
on during season 1 episode 5. i know there were
a lot of people in the last trailer because
there's a close-up shot of the rear of this
bike that actually looks a lot like the outline of
boba fett's jet pack so a lot of people think that
because timothy oliphant was seen in boba fett's
armor on the set of the mandalorian season 2
that he'll be the cobb vance character from the
books the person who just finds boba fett's armor
and starts using it and this might wind up being
his character it does sound like he might show up
on tatooine so when we see boba fett finally
during season 2 he won't actually be wearing
his armor he'll look a little bit different but
he is supposed to be played by temura morrison
then we get the same scene of him entering the
fighting arena with the gomorians just going at it
in the ring and he starts talking to the bison the
creature with one eye about baby yoda the bisons
are actually a race that are native to biss in
the deep core as the name implies in dark empire
it was where he stored all of his younger clones
that were supposed to be around age 18 something
they kind of did during rise of skywalker with
all the clones but we get a much longer version of
that takedown scene with the whistling birds and
baby yoda just yeeting closing his shell everyone
i've seen posting about this scene thinks that
this character is actually being played secret
guest cameo by either john favreau or mark hamill
himself because mark hamill had a super secret
cameo as the ev99 droids serving people in the mos
eisley cantina during season 1 and you wouldn't
have known it was him from the sound of his voice
unless they told you that it was him we'll have to
wait to the credits of the episode to actually
find out who it really is but it doesn't sound
exactly like either one of them so post all your
theories about who this might be in the comments
then we get a much longer scene of that chase
scene with the scout troopers trying to catch who
we now see is cara dune grief karga and horatio
sands from saturday night live fame from season
one episode one you probably remember him from
that very first episode he was the mandalorian's
first bounty from the series whatever is happening
in this it looks like some sort of forced escape
they've stolen a troop transport you probably
recognize it from season 1 episode 7 and episode
8 is the exact same transport that they rode into
town on people think that this planet might be
solace because of all the black rock and the lava
in the background but it could be back on navarro
it could be somewhere else anytime i see lava
planets in star wars i always feel like they're
trying to make some sort of mustafa reference too
the way the mandalorian series is constructed they
just pull from all over the place from the clone
wars from the original trilogy even a little bit
from the prequels but all this other footage is
from that same imperial base that they infiltrate
all these different action scenes it could
have something to do with them rescuing
mando's bounty from season one because they
need him for something else there's a much
longer scene of all the thai outlanders taking
off with the wings folding up coming after them
probably later during the chase scene then you
have the mandalorian taking off in his jet pack
with his big call to action here we go there's a
little bit of new baby yoda footage during this
like you see him peeking from around the bulkhead
here in surprise or curiosity it doesn't seem like
anything really dangerous is happening here and it
doesn't seem like the same metal of the bulkheads
from the imperial base a lot of the footage
of him throughout the episodes and season one
was just crawling around the ship just poking
around in things or trying to hide from some
of the other bounty hunters like episode six so
don't be surprised if he starts just popping up
all over the place inside the razor crest in
really small moments if a lot of these scenes seem
familiar too it's because they cut the trailer to
remind you of a lot of the highlights and action
scenes from season one like him taking off in
his jet pack to take down moff gideon's thai
outlander so i know there are a ton of questions
where's ahsoka in all this where are the other
mandalorians that he speaks of in the trailer
maybe if i find other mandalorians they can
help guide me what about the darksaber what about
moff gideon's backstory there's been very little
moff gideon in any of this footage if any and
then also what about season three and season
four that giancarlo esposito was talking about
i've already done a video about that too so if
you didn't hear giancarlo esposito made this funny
comment he was kind of joking kind of not joking
that we would really get answers about the big
questions that the show raises by season four
so even though they're supposed to start filming
season three later this year before the end of
2020 so that they can get it out by next year
on a regular yearly schedule they'll probably
just roll straight through into season four just
because the show is so overwhelmingly popular they
just want to get it out as fast as possible they
should also tell you about the fate of moth gideon
during season 2 as well i know a lot of people are
wondering if the mandalorian is ever gonna wield
the darksaber himself he'd have to take it from
off gideon in the way giancarlo esposito talks
about it that's probably not gonna happen during
season 2 the whole thing with introducing more
mandalorians on the show obviously is probably
just an intro for katee sackhoff's bo katan kryze
character i don't know if she's actually been
confirmed yet ahsoka is one of the few characters
including boba fett that i know has been confirmed
but i think katee sakhoff was also announced by
some of the big trade publications you probably
saw there were some recent rumors about her
character live-action boca tan crees showing up
on another mandalorian spin-off series that star
wars is going to be doing in the next couple of
years or that they might be doing that has not
been confirmed yet though supposedly they're also
thinking about doing a spin-off series for cara
dune i think it makes sense it just depends on
how excited you are at the thought of akara dune
series they said that they were developing a
number of different spin-off series from the
mandalorian last year so it could be any number
of different types of shows that they just pull
out of whatever stories they set up during season
2 for the most part as far as i know baby yoda
will always stay on the mandalorian main series
pedro pascal will always be on the main series
but other characters will come and go there was
also a rumored ahsoka series and i know obviously
she didn't show up in this trailer footage either
a lot of people were expecting to see her but i
think because it's such a big deal finally doing
her in live action they just want to hold that
close to their vest so they're not going to reveal
her until the actual episode where she shows up
remember they didn't show any baby yoda marketing
material until after episode 1 had released last
year but if you spotted any other big star wars
easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't mention
in the video just write them below in the
comments in big reminder season 2 episode 1
is releasing friday october 30th all my episode
videos will post on fridays as long as you have
alerts enabled from my channel you should see all
those videos when they post what's going to happen
is they're doing one episode per week and then
after the mandalorian is done they'll do avengers
wandavision episodes it's not on the release
schedule for november which means they're probably
going to release wandavision in december like
they originally said they were going to do i'll
be doing separate videos about that so just look
out for my marvel wandavision videos and i'll
be talking about the series during those while
you wait for everything click here to watch that
other big mandalorian season 2 trailer a billion
more times and click here to learn about that new
spider-man 3 spider-verse rumor thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!